you've had the
fortunate nature of starting very early
yeah being able to build an audience and
a reputation for being reliable and now
you're at that point I think if somebody
had started again from Gone Gone style
today yeah I think they'd struggle that
is yeah that is scripted content that's
not trash taste trash days are I will
talk about [__] yeah I mean would you
agree that if Gartner started today
doing a similar style it would be a lot
tougher
I don't think so
um I think if I started today I would go
for a different approach a different
style yeah uh yeah it's okay so okay
yeah like to me in terms like making
content you always got to make something
that someone isn't already doing better
and the problem if I started today is
I'm already making my content right so
the only anime is me not the only enemy
is me like I I'm I've done a I've done a
lot uh I've done a lot I've put many
years making like my style of content so
if I started again I'd probably make a
completely different style account right
still anime but just a different story
do you think it's oh sorry no I was just
asking like how would it be different
okay so if I started now I'd probably be
making stuff on more like Theory and
like kind of like that Styler content
everyone does that power scale don't do
that not power scale I I would okay
here's the thing here's like here's what
I would do a lot of people are making
Theory kinds of content but I would try
to find a way that to make that kind of
content that
has not like is not like totally
saturated you know because I love that
yeah there is a lot of that kind of like
Theory kind of content and that's very
very popular right now
um I feel like there is a kind of like
Gap to be like here is some really I I
don't want to give everything away in
case I I mean you could honestly do that
now
I have a question in every single
YouTube genre there are multiple people
who are crushing it and doing well yeah
yeah why does it feel like in anime
you have been the guy and there's not
been much else happening like there are
some YouTubers anime doesn't make money
there are some other big YouTubers who
talk about anime they definitely are but
there's no one I feel that has been at
your level and I feel like that's super
red okay YouTube yeah like I I will
answer this because like I know this now
that I've like met other YouTubers in my
um my field or other like massive
YouTubers yeah like considering like
looking at this from a business
perspective it's terrible I as a huge as
a purely anime YouTuber and uh I'm
making like [__] crumbs compared to
YouTubers My Level my subscriber my
account yeah so if I'm like the top
anime YouTuber what does that what does
that mean about incentive to grow yeah
what does that say about a lot of people
trying to like find their footing in my
field you know yeah I mean I think a lot
of talents of people who covered anime
initially so
pivoted yeah out of it like John and you
oh yeah you yeah
uh you know I think a lot of creators
realized early on that like I can't just
be a bad anime yeah
um and so I mean like Johnny I think is
a prime example of that John is such a
talented Storyteller super outpatient
yeah so good at making videos so good
Italian story and I I think it's the one
of the best things that ever happened is
that on YouTube he just just stopped
talking about anime as much yeah because
I love his videos I think he makes great
videos about stuff he just likes even if
I don't care about his wrestling videos
sometimes sorry John I still watch him I
still watch his wrestling videos yeah
[__] John I don't give a [__] about
wrestling but John I don't either until
I watch the video and I'm like okay I
don't care now yeah and so I mean yeah I
think he does a great job and I I think
yeah I think a lot of anime YouTubers
realize early on or at some point
they're like hold on I can take
everything I've learned from this yeah
and just apply it to a more general
purpose yeah and probably succeed a
little bit more yeah well that's that's
exactly what I did like I I kind of got
to the point where I I for one
personally was kind of getting like
bored of making anime content because of
how repetitive it was and kind of how in
like like non-innovative it was uh you
know because there's only so many like
creative ways that you can make and like
pure anime content right and obviously
there are people like God and you know
other people who can still do content
like that and it'd be [__] amazing
but me personally I realized like okay I
do like this whole anime thing but at
the same time there are also other
elements especially about Japanese
culture that I have a massive passion
for and I want to explore those a little
bit you're also native and Japanese it's
such a waste to be just talking about
anime all the time exactly and that's
why I like you know be covering more
yeah stuff that takes advantage of your
ability exactly and that's why like you
know I've been doing more of those like
interview videos and like yeah kind of
covering Japanese news and like kind of
using that skill that I never was aware
of that I had to be I was in my
advantage I would kill for the your
ability in Japanese I think I'd be able
to make such different videos but I'll
never ever even if I got fluent it's
like I'd still never be the same level
that would allow me to open up those
doors and at the same age
that would make it interesting but you
know I think uh I think one thing that
we've done really well is that we go for
different angles into this yeah if you
never use the same topic why don't you
make more Wells content
there's not a demand there's no one
cares I think I think honestly there's
ways I could do it yeah there's some
videos there's some angles I could
explore yeah okay you say that but on my
second Channel like a couple of months
ago I made a video just as a test of top
10 Australian uh musical bands that are
underrated in my opinion that video at
20 000 views you're [__] full no I
think I think that there's a way I could
tell a story in a way but it would have
to be so well done yeah yeah and I have
to put so much work into it that it it
like
you kind of forget that when you live
somewhere you're like okay I kind of
have to make content around this area
and if I want to expand new content in
other countries
that's a huge commitment yeah especially
if we're talking about the level of
quality we need to be able to make
something that people would actually
watch yeah absolutely like I don't know
there's certainly some fun videos there
must be some cool content like I I I
watch videos about Farm dudes being a
farmer like and I like that I think it's
fun yeah right but like what would I add
by doing that nothing I need to make
more of an in-depth story if it
warranted me going out there and even
then it's like okay what am I what would
I talk about I don't know I I feel like
it's cool if you can show off you know
some of the [__] culture that you
grew up in and like you have the
opportunity it's it's tough you know
it's tough but I would like to I would
personally like yeah I mean you would
but I think a lot of people wouldn't
it's not Sensational enough for YouTube
It's the vocal minority right but I I
knew right away when I was getting into
YouTube and I started making some
especially enough money to start looking
at this like okay I can I can I can
maybe at some point pay rent soon
that's when I kind of decided I was like
I gotta change it up I gotta figure out
how to yeah good thing you're not as
Sebastian go anymore I wouldn't be here
but like you know one thing that I've
always had a lot of
um conversations with a lot of YouTubers
is when they want to change up their
content they want results like that yeah
they want it they want to change they
want it to be done yeah I don't know you
did it took me like a year and a half
two years it doesn't happen to
transition off there yeah like that's
not that's not a quick process like
you've given
if you want to gain an audience whilst
also keeping the audience you have happy
you can say [__] it to your audience you
can be like [__] them I'm gonna make new
stuff I'll find a new audience you can
do that and that's a legit strategy but
you've got to be okay with bombing for a
while yeah but it can't work and
creators have done it but I was more so
concerned and I think a lot of creators
are there like I want to keep the
numbers going but transition it and that
took like two years of making weird [__]
that was very in between and still
including Sebastian content but trying
to you know get people to yeah
experimental stuff like let's watch
let's watch me
um voice act an anime character while
wearing that character's costume and
playing a game that requires me to
control the volume yeah that's a video
idea I had and I made and I don't know
why but I think it did okay at the time
I think it for me weirdly the turning
point where it really kicked off uh was
the cosplay videos remember those videos
I used to do yeah I remember those I
remember those those videos used to
crush and I this is the first time I
ever had videos that really did really
well yeah it was just me putting on dumb
[__] costumes and I was like okay
here we go this is like finally I found
a series yeah that uses anime in a
creative way without relying on any uh
me actually getting into the IP yeah and
that really like allowed me to make
these other videos that really did well
and that was kind of what changed
everything for me
um I mean I guess I haven't really
stopped them but I kind of felt like
they were done I just felt like it was
over like I felt like there was nothing
more I could do and anything else I
would do was kind of arbitrary to the
street I I bought a bunch more so I have
more yeah from like a year ago so I
couldn't wear them I think they're like
chainsaw man stuff yeah and I could wear
it and it could work and it could be a
funny video but I just I don't know I I
just feel like it kind of run its course
I don't know but I I feel like over that
year your standards of what is suitable
for the main Channel this could
definitely you say that but I'm just
bashing out crying games so like who's
really but the problem is the cranking
videos Crash people love them yeah they
do really well and also the easiest part
is that they're easy to film
um because a lot of the videos that we
do with like Tahoe or we do whatever
it's like if you take too long yeah it
takes so long to make and the cranking
videos I can call up the the place that
I filmed that and I'd be like hey can I
come film and they're like yeah so it's
good it's really easy and it's a great
way to do more collaboration because I
miss doing collaboration yeah uh and so
it's kind of like all right well I guess
I'm I'm the crane game guy now yeah
that's why I like doing it it's fun it's
chill yeah and it works man I care about
live streaming and stuff more which is
like
YouTube which is so weird because it's
like I had I spent like seven years of
my life dedicated to this one idea and
this one thing and this one concept and
then I'm like yes you know what [__] it
from change
hey man if if that if that satisfies you
then I say